bang bang what's up everyone lunch money
time
well while she's trying to get rich the
rest of us just trying to get our lunch
money right
i'm here with the beautiful intelligent
polina pompliano
she's got pimp pee pee you don't have uh
shoulder pads on but you have the old
school it looks like you should be
riding in a carriage behind a
truck before the cowboys come and try to
steal all your wealth
you know what i'm talking about now in
the old olden days in the 1800s when
they wore those little things on their
uh jacket inside the carriage
it was only the rich people who did it
don't worry uh speaking of
rich get money get paid blockfy is now a
sponsor of lunch money
go and get an interest bearing account
where you can earn up to 8.6
apy it is awesome awesome not awesome
awesome you can do that at blockfy.com
lunch money i'm an investor and a very
very happy user
every first monday of the month you just
get
money deposited from the interest
payments it's so cool you open your
email bam
more money awesome let's do it block
five.com lunch money whoo
are you good i'm good are you ready to
knock this out it took 65 seconds
all right beiru at least a hundred
people were killed and more than four
thousand
injured following a massive explosion
that rocked the poor
area of the lebanese capital of beirut
the cause of the original fire was not
immediately known however
multiple video angles showed an enormous
mushroom cloud blast
that flattened a number of surrounding
buildings
and the explosion comes as the country
finds itself amid a spiraling economic
and political crisis
driven by widespread corruption and
fiscal mismanagement
public protests drove out former prime
minister saad hariri in recent months
so can i give you my take i would love
your take this is very sad
i know and and my take is that
people think that the world can just
in the middle of the covet pandemic but
what we have to remember
is that there's um still a lot of
political you know unrest and
there's tropical storms and the world
continues
and we're gonna kind of have to figure
it out how to navigate this stuff
even in the midst of a pandemic well and
on top of that i think that
you've got a situation where uh
a lot of people have died um there's
thousands injured so just that alone
like i don't care what the cause is
um you just you know your thoughts and
kind of your heart and everything goes
out to these people and you just hope
that people
generally are okay right and obviously
with 30
40 people dead um that they're not uh
going to be okay and that affects not
only those people but it affects their
families their friends their communities
all this kind of stuff
um and then you get into the like why
did this happen
and i've seen everything from uh more of
the
like hey was this an attack types uh
talk track
to oh this was just a fireworks uh
facility
i have no clue um what
what happened uh there seems to be
multiple
explosions uh which is a little bit
weird
um and so what you really just go back
to is like
we're all human we're all going to die
one day and while we're here on earth we
should spend as much time as possible
peacefully and if we can't do that then
that's just really sad and so
um you know regardless of what's
happened here i think that this is just
a reminder that
um as polina said the world keeps
spinning but also uh the world's better
off when we all get along rather than
fight so yeah i hate this stuff man
all right what's up with the i say yes
so isaias is the name of the tropical
storm that's
whipping up eastern u.s you know why
it's so bad
what's because because it's mad that
it's got a dumb name it's like oh y'all
want to name me i say yes all right i'm
coming
well another sad uh piece of news at
least six people were killed as the
tropical storm
spawned tornadoes and dumped rain
tuesday
there's a number of floods fires people
are without power
um and yeah it's isaiah sustained top
winds of up to 65 miles an hour
per hour more than 18 hours after coming
ashore and it's still going
so in i read uh i read a newsletter
today um
fortune's uh ceo wrote he said
yeah so it's interesting because how do
you
practice social distancing as you
evacuate people
like it's just all these things that we
have to think about yeah
the only thing i will caveat with is
like we had tens of thousands of people
in the street protesting and they're
claiming that it had nothing to do with
contributing to
the rise in uh coronavirus cases
and supposedly what they're saying is oh
people had masks on and they were
outside
so if you're evacuating right you're
likely to be outside if you have a mask
on
uh and if you're not outside then you're
probably in a car but you're not it's
not like you're in a car with
you know 50 other people probably your
family you're in your house with
so we'll see yes there is definitely
some things
now if all of a sudden you've got like
um i'm going to get this wrong but like
i'll call them refugee uh centers like
everyone's going like a gymnasium or
something
like that then of course there's going
to be concerns uh with how you
can do stuff my point is just yeah like
just because there's a global pandemic
doesn't mean
you know the world stops going yeah it's
pretty crazy it was raining hard here
yesterday i thought the thing had shown
up but i guess i wasn't even part of it
so
all right what's going on with school
closures so basically the new school
year is around the corner
you know if uh schools don't reopen
there's a lot of parents who are at risk
to stop working entirely
because they have no child care so
nearly a third of pre-pandemic u.s labor
force has kids at home
and about 15 of the workforce falls into
at least two of those three
risk categories which are single parents
parent and parents with
uh young children it's crazy to me
how uh little i understood about the
importance of
school not care on the educational
impact so like
it was obvious okay cool we're supposed
to send kids to school to get educated
but
when you really start to understand
things like um
the impact uh school provides and the
opportunity provides for parents to go
to work
right because then they don't have to
leave their kids at home they can send
them to school uh you look at how many
kids in the united states
count on that meal at school as a core
piece of their diet right
like you just when you think of school i
think before these types of situations
you just think as on the education front
but there's a lot of elements that go
into it and then on top of that
you then start to think about like all
of the people that a school employs so
you have the teachers obviously then
you've got the administrative staff
then you've got the janitorial staff
then you've got all the support um you
know systems in place
uh and then there's businesses impacted
by like just when you shut down a school
that the ripple of impact across
people and businesses is incredible i
don't know why i always think of this
but i watched a documentary
um and it featured this family uh
basically that
the opioid pandemic is ravaging a lot of
states
and this little girl both of her parents
one of them was
in prison and the other one was addicted
to opioids
so her going to school was literally the
most stable part of her day
and and she enjoyed going to school
because it allowed her to leave that
house um so i think about people like
that like not everybody has a stable
home not everybody has that type of
caring educational environment um
and so it's just i i'm really sad about
it
and i just don't know it's the world we
live in
it's uh it's not good um what's going on
oh speaking of not good
what's up with anthony lewandowski
anthony levandowski do you remember who
he was
i know who anthony lewandowski is i take
no credit even though he shared the same
first name
this is anthony's in trouble he's the
former google engineer and serial
entrepreneur who was at the center of a
lawsuit between
uber and waymo has been sentenced to 18
months on one count of stealing trade
secrets absolutely insane wow
and uh the i didn't realize that he
potentially was going to go to jail i
thought that he would just get
massive uh financial um situation
but he had to file bankruptcy because
there's a very big
judgment against like 125 million
dollars um and then on top of that
uh now he's going to jail and he i don't
know if you saw
counter sued or not maybe not
counter-strike but sued uber
that was a while ago no a new one i
think in the last couple of days for
over 4 billion dollars
and so like this whole thing is just
crazy uh it involves a google engineer
who left
steel trade secrets yeah he took files
with him when he left google he set up a
company but that company was set up
with the understanding that uber was
going to acquire it uber ended up
acquiring it
like all this crazy stuff happened um
and you end up with a guy now going to
jail for 18 months it's
pretty sad frankly the new york times
so i was recently reading a paper i
wrote in college about how i sounded
like a dinosaur i was like
well newspapers are stuck in this really
hard situation
where you know they rely on the majority
of their revenue coming from
uh print where they have to move on to
cyber space but they can't move to
cyberspace
because they're tied to these this print
ad revenue
so today digital revenue for the new
york times exceeded its print revenue
for the first time in history and if
you're
in media you know this is a big ass deal
this has never happened before this like
digital advertising is one small
portion of what you get in print
but their subscription revenue has been
really strong
so yeah but the times total revenue
decreased by 7.5 percent
to 403 million
uh so they're actually down on the year
um and the ad revenue uh to fall between
50 and 55 percent
uh or i'm sorry the ad revenue it fell
between 50 and 55
because there's lower demand and on top
of that
i'm sorry advertising revenue was the
hardest hit falling by 43
which they thought was going to be 50 55
so it was better than they thought but
they still fell
43 and so the revenue ended up falling
7.5
the craziest part to me is not that
digital revenue now surpasses other
revenue
it's the fact that why hadn't this
happened five years ago the internet has
been around forever i know
yeah that's crazy to me like coming from
the internet you know perspective of the
world
the fact that people are still
advertising in newspapers well the fact
that i wrote that paper in 2010
and so they expect the third quarter
revenue the ad revenue
the q3 to decline about 35 to 40 percent
compared to a year
ago it's just they're gonna get
decimated
if you're still an ad based business
especially if people are just paying for
this
especially especially but
i i know it's just they're stuck in a
hard place because this is
i mean literally newspapers should have
done this
back in 2010 when i wrote my paper but
the problem is they were tied
to that revenue and they couldn't get
out so now it's like
now is like this is the time if you
can't get online if you can't figure it
out figure out subscriptions paywalls
whatever you have to do
if you can't figure how how to make
money online you're screwed
so i feel like everything we're talking
about today is sad all right what's up
with the
wakka rasaya sia is that how you
pronounce it i don't know but
okay so this is crazy are you ready is
that how you pronounce it wakka rasaya
sia so
this is happening in japan uh basically
if you want a divorce
there are these agents you know how here
in america you're like you hire a
private investigator to find out if
somebody's cheating
but there it's a business if you want a
divorce
you have to be able to show proof and
evidence and photos and you have to be
able to
um kind of have both people agree it's
really hard if one person
doesn't want to get divorced so they
hire someone to go seduce
the partner and have them fall in love
so then they can take pictures and show
the court look like
she's falling in love with another man i
gotta get divorced and it avoids
confrontation
yeah i'm down for a wakka rasia or
whatever this is this is that's funny as
hell
so are you kidding me it's a crazy big
this is a real thing it's a huge
industry
um and so okay so basically it helps you
avoid confrontation
it's a way in the short term of
resolving a difficult situation without
conflict
and your wife is much more likely to
agree to a divorce if she's in love with
someone else and
wants to move on the fees range from
like 3 000 pounds
to 145 000 pounds can you imagine
hitting somebody with hey man all right
i need you to go seduce my wife and i'm
gonna pay you
thousands of dollars or hundreds of
thousands of dollars
and then would turn around and in the
divorce give her fifty percent too
that's like massive expensive ass
decision there dude well but it's just
it makes it easier to get divorced
especially when one spouse won't agree
but if they're in love with someone else
imagine finding out that person is a
licensed wakara garcia
well what happens when they realize that
they're catfished they were like oh i
thought i was in love
i got divorced and then this guy's like
oh sorry my uh
my term here is up my contract is up so
i'm going to see you later
and so because you think that they have
sex with the uh okay we don't have to
get into all that
now that's a legitimate question is that
part of the contract hold on but because
there was a situation early on with a
wakara sasia
who um really fell in love with the
person they were supposed to only be
seducing
but then something happened and he
killed her so now
you know it's just a crazy story so now
you have to be licensed
and you have to prove that you're a
professional and all that it's a very
legitimized noun
so your professional scumbag got it
would you ever pay somebody to like
seduce me
nah would you pay someone to seduce me
people probably would do it for free
okay so are you ready for my joke yeah
what joke you got for me i'm still
thinking about it somebody would seduce
me for free
go ahead what you gonna do for free
oh i'm in trouble all right go just tell
the joke
we're about to have such a long
conversation after this go see my walk
of russia
cancel all your meetings um okay what do
you call an argument between
two electric companies
a lightning rod a power struggle
i mean that's a clever one it's not
funny but it's clever i thought it was
really funny you didn't even
you thought it was so funny that it
caused you to go to sleep okay guys
that's it for lunch monday today don't
forget
paulina comes from the 1860s in her
little carriage riding down the street
looking for oh you mean my little poof
yeah oh i don't even see that
okay that's like that would be like me
putting on a shirt and being like oh i
didn't realize i had a sleeve right here
that's that's part of your style i'm
calling a wakaracia
hey if you're uh if you're a legit one
hit me up
i'll meet you at the supermarket all
right that's it for lunch money today
while wall street's trying to get rich
the rest of us try and get our lunch
money right
paulina hopefully will let me live
another day to see you guys tomorrow
see ya we'll see bang bang
hope you guys enjoyed this episode of
lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan what
you're a bigger fan of block five than
you are of me block flies my second
favorite thing in the world behind
polina
they've got three products they can give
you a us dollar loan
you can earn up to eight point six
percent interest on an interest-bearing
account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends